108 اشخاص قتلوا في الحوله وهذا عدد كبير
في يوم واحد فقط ما اثار الحزن والغضب في
ارجاء البلاد فنصف الضحايا لا يهددون احدا
في سوريا لانهم من الاطفال الذين لم تبلغ
اعمارهم العاشره والله انا غسلت اشهد الله
تس اطفال اقل من من شهور عمره شو سو هذا
هذا يحمل قاض اربيج ما يحمل يج والله نحن
بشر والله نحن بشر والله عم يعتبرنا اقل
من الحمير عم يعاملونا اقل من الحمير نحن
مخلوقين من خلق الله ناشطو المعارضه
اتهموا الحكومه السوريه وميليشياتها
بتنفيذ المجزره بينما اتهمت الحكومه
السوريه من تصفهم بالمجموعات الارهابيه
بذلك واصفه المزاعم ضدها بانها تسونامي من
الاكاذيب ننفي بشكل
قاطع مسؤوليه القوات الحكوميه عن هذه
المجزره التي وقعت والمدان بشده وزير
الخارجيه البريطاني ويليام هيج وصفها
باكاذيب الحكومه السوريه القاء اللوم من
قبل الحكومه السوريه تجاه ما يحدث في
البلاد على غيرهم تكتيك معروف لدى الحكومه
هدفه التهرب من مسؤوليه اعمال العنف
والدمار في البلاد هذا وقد انتشرت مقاطع
فيديو مختلفه تظهر الضحايا والدمار الذي
لحق بالحول حيث يظهر هذا الفيديو جثثا
لنساء واطفال متكدس داخل غرفه صغيره صور
مؤلمه لجثث اطفال مليئه بالدماء مزلقه
جماجم بعضهم عن اجسامهم وبرغم وجود
المراقبين الدوليين في سوريا شهدت البلاد
هذه المجزره فالمراد ليس لديهم سلطه
لايقاف العنف سوى الدعوه الى تهدئه
الاوضاع في
البلاد يجب ايقاف العنف والقتل اولا لكي
نتمكن من اسعاف المصابين وازاله جثث
القتلى وسارع مجلس الامن بالامم المتحده
الى عقد اجتماع قصير لمناقشه الاوضاع في
سوريا واستبعد نائب السفير الروسي في
الامم المتحده حصول اي تحرك سريع حل
الازمه من الصعب جدا تخيل ان تقوم الحكومه
السوريه بقصف ليس فقط القرى بل بقتل اكثر
من 40 امراه و3 طفلا دون العاشره
ايضا وبينما يتزايد غضب المجتمع الدولي
يدفع الاطفال الابرياء ثمن هدنه مكتوبه
على الاوراق فقط دون تطبيق فعلي على ارض
الواقع